questa pagnotta di pane è stata cotta
due giorni fa ma in realtà una parte di
essa che la compone fisicamente a 23
anni in questi 15 minuti cercherò di
spiegarvi come ho fatto ad arrivare a
questa pagnotta e anche che cosa vuol
dire per me avere passione io nasco in
una famiglia di Mugnai da bambino sono
la terza generazione di una famiglia di
Mugnai da bambino anziché fare i
castelli di sabbia facevo le montagne di
farina nascono in un mondo di materia
prima di contadini che partono dalla
Terra
la prima volta che ho capito in maniera
consapevole che cosa voleva dire aver
passione era il 2007 ero seduto nel
cortile del mio mulino di famiglia e
accanto a me avevo mio nonno e mio padre
ai tempi
la nostra famiglia produceva Una
piccolissima parte di farine da
agricoltura biologica e tutto il resto
della produzione erano farine da
agricoltura convenzionale
Mio padre ha sempre avuto l'idea che
coltivava in maniera sostenibile senza
l'utilizzo della chimica dei pesticidi
potesse giovare non soltanto alla terra
ma soprattutto alle persone che mangiamo
nei nostri prodotti le nostre farine e
soprattutto agli agricoltori che nei
campi ci lavoravano mio nonno quel
giorno nel mulino mi disse una frase
importantissima mio nonno aveva fatto
solo la quinta elementare classe 1923 ma
mi disse quel giorno La terra è stanca
La terra è stanca dei continui pesticidi
erbicidi fungicidi dobbiamo ritornare a
coltivare in maniera sostenibile per
ritornare a dare alla terra un futuro
bene in quell'estate la mia famiglia
decise di
passare esclusivamente alla macinazione
di cereali provenienti da agricoltura
biologica non fu una scelta facile in
pochi mesi perdemmo il 90% dei clienti
era un bel problema fare farine ci dava
da vivere bisognava scegliere se
guardare il guadagno economico oppure
seguire la propria passione
avevo paura
chiesi a mio padre che cosa avremmo
fatto e lui mi disse nella vita bisogna
lottare per le cose in cui si crede
anche se queste Magari sono difficili e
magari non sono giuste Ti portano a
sbagliare Mi ricordo ancora il nodo che
avevo allo stomaco quel giorno quando
sei immerso nell'insicurezza non sai se
la scelta che stai facendo sia quella
giusta oppure che ti porta a un disastro
a un grande sbaglio però ero mi sentivo
anche bene perché
guardando negli occhi mio padre
quasi impercettibilmente sorridevano
erano occhi intrisi di passione e capì
che molte volte lo capii un po' dopo ma
se mischiamo alla nostra paura la
mischiamo con la nostra passione che
cosa Diamo vita Diamo vita al coraggio
Al coraggio che ci fa fare delle scelte
magari non facili che magari ci portano
anche a sbagliare però che ti fanno
sentire a posto con te stesso
Io oggi sono Mugnaio ma un Mugnaio un
po' particolare Sono uno dei pochissimi
forse Mugnai panificatori Perché più che
la passione per la farina io da sempre
avuto la passione di mischiare gli
elementi di creare con la farina non
sono figlio d'arte a casa mia nessuno fa
o faceva pane ma io mi ricordo che fin
da ragazzino quando impastava Acqua
Farina mi sentivo bene
ho sempre pensato alle farine Come dei
colori ha dei colori che se mischiati
bene che se questi colori sono di alta
qualità danno vita delle vere e proprie
opere d'arte come il pane la pizza i
dolci Non a caso L'arte di panificare si
chiama Arte Bianca
appassionata di lievitazione faccio la
mia prima pizza a 12 anni era il
compleanno di mia madre volevo farle un
regalo un regalo che venisse proprio da
me fatto con le mie mani questa pizza fu
un disastro mia madre pianse per la
commozione io piangi per la rabbia di
non esserci riuscito Avrei potuto
lasciar stare però in realtà dopo due
anni scopro l'esistenza del lievito
madre Chi di voi sa cos'è il lievito
madre Probabilmente dopo il lockdown
vedo mai alzate Dopo lockdown
praticamente tutti lo sappiamo ma 23
anni fa il lievito madre era una
creatura misteriosa quasi mitologica
nessuno sapeva cos'era il lievito madre
è un impasto di acqua e farina che
miscelati insieme dopo un po' di tempo
fermentando danno vita danno vita danno
vita a una colonia di batteri e di
funghi lieviti appunto bene io un giorno
di inizio estate diventi tre anni fa
decido di provare a creare il mio
lievito madre impasto Acqua e Farina E
li metto in un barattolo a fermentare
sotto l'albero di ulivo che è presente
nel cortile del mio mulino mi ricordo
chi ero impaziente dopo due o tre ore
andavo a vedere che cosa succedeva non
avevo nessuno a cui chiedere come si
faceva ma non succedeva niente passa la
prima notte il mattino vado a vedere e
quella pastella di Acqua e Farina era
così decido un po' di lasciarlo lì però
non ci pensavo passa la seconda notte
quel mattino vado a vedere quel
barattolo ed era diventata una cosa
completamente diversa abbiamo una
consistenza diversa un odore diverso ero
per la prima volta entrato in contatto
con la magia dei lieviti bene questo
pane che vedete qui a fianco a me è
stato fatto proprio con lievito madre
che ho creato 23 anni fa ma il lievito
madre bisogna accudirlo bisogna nutrirlo
come la passione ci vuole costanza e ci
vuole anche un po' di fiducia in quello
che succederà
da lì non mi sono più fermato oggi Sono
23 anni che faccio pane pizza perché il
lievito è un po' come la passione è un
iniettore di vita che il lievito
incontrando acqua e farina
moltiplicandosi La trasforma la
trasforma in qualcosa di buono e la
passione è così è contagiosa può essere
contagiosa e quando la incontriamo ci
può far diventare qualcosa di migliori è
un ingrediente come la passione da sola
non basta però senza di essa non si
ottengono dei risultati eccellenti
Io penso che la passione vera sia questo
fare delle cose che ti senti dentro che
non sono dettate dalla società chi me lo
faceva fare ad impastare Acqua e Farina
E fare il pane non andava di moda non
era una cosa bella però a me a impastare
mi faceva stare bene e questo penso che
sia la cosa più importante che dobbiamo
fare quando andiamo a cercarla la nostra
passione allo stesso modo arriva il
momento in cui devo scegliere quale
università fare è un momento difficile
soprattutto quando sei ragazzo e tutti
ti danno consigli devi far questo devi
fare l'altro se avessi seguito la
razionalità e la logica è anche un po' i
consigli della mia famiglia
probabilmente avrei fatto economia
agraria o magari Scienze
dell'alimentazione Siccome il pane lo
facevo già da tempo ma io decisi di
coltivare il percorso di un'altra grande
mia passione che probabilmente lì per lì
non c'entrava niente ma mi piaceva la
comunicazione io da sempre da bambino mi
piaceva scrivere mi piaceva comunicare
e quindi decisi di intraprendere un
percorso di studi nella università di
Torino in scienze della comunicazione e
Finalmente mi laureo
queste due grandi passioni di
lievitazione la comunicazione che
sembravano non centrare niente tra loro
si incontrano prepotentemente in quella
strana primavera del 2020 in cui tutti
ci siamo ritrovati rinchiusi nelle
nostre case prima di quel giorno
viaggiavo 250 giorni all'anno per
consulenze nel mondo professionale al
mondo della panificazione non vedevo
quasi mai la mia famiglia probabilmente
in quel momento in cui ci siamo
ritrovati a casa avrei potuto anche tra
virgolette godermi un po' di relax ma ho
seguito il mio istinto la mia passione e
anche un po' i consigli di mia moglie
che mi vedeva fermo come una meba sul
divano e mi ha detto qui non andiamo
bene e quindi ricevevo tutti i giorni
messaggi i primi giorni di lockdown
ricevevo tanti messaggi dei miei amici
che mi conoscevano e che mi chiedevano
delle ricette per fare il pane o la
pizza Chi di voi non ha Impastato almeno
una volta il lockdown E quindi che cosa
succede io dopo dopo un po' di giorni
che mandavo questi messaggi mi sono
accorto che potevo fare qualcosa sempre
di più potevo fare incontrare le mie due
passioni che cosa faccio avevo un
profilo Instagram e decido di fare delle
dirette su Instagram dove facevo tutte
le ricette che avevo imparato dispensavo
consigli di tutto quello che avevo
imparato in tanti anni del mondo
professionale Tra queste persone con cui
facevo le dirette Ah non vi ho detto
anche che ho ingrassato tutto il
condominio che era il condominio più
felice della mia città perché mangiava
delle cose buonissime tutti felici e tra
queste dirette ci fu Tra le tante
persone gli amici con cui mi colleghiamo
ci fu Antonella Clerici a cui un giorno
mandai un messaggio e le dissi Antonella
Ti va di fare una cucinata insieme
naturalmente via Instagram lei mi
rispose subito di sì da una diretta
diventavano due poi una settimana e poi
due a settimana si divertì ci divertivo
tantissimo e mi accorsi che potevo
finalmente condividere la mia passione
con tantissime altre persone che la
passione era contagiosa e a fine del
primo lockdown a inizio estate
ad Antonella chiedono di fare un nuovo
programma televisivo su Rai 1 la prima
persona che chiama sono io mi ricordo
ancora quella telefonata mi chiama mi fa
vorrei fare il pane quotidiano in
diretta tutti i giorni Io naturalmente
accettai e dal 28 settembre del 2020 Ho
iniziato una nuova avventura su Rai 1
tutti i giorni alle 12 per questo
programma che si chiama è sempre
mezzogiorno
Oggi sono passati tre anni da quel
momento sono successe tantissime cose ci
sono stati dei momenti molto difficili e
dei momenti anche molto belli ad oggi
sono più di 500 le ricette che ho fatto
tutte diverse ogni giorno della
settimana di pane di pizza e di dolci ho
scritto due libri uno sul pane e uno
sulla pizza le mie due grandi passioni
tengo corsi online in presenza sul mondo
degli evitati delle lievitazioni E ora
anche un programma tutto mio su Food
network nel forno di casa tua
E questa forma di pane che vedete qui
accanto a me è un po' quella che
rappresenta la mia storia quella che
rappresenta anche un po' la storia del
pane che è comunicazione Questa è una
riproduzione che ho fatto del pane di
Vicovaro un piccolo paese alle porte di
Roma tutti i pani Soprattutto quelli
antichi vogliono sempre comunicare
qualcosa questa forma rotonda indica la
circolarità della vita
e solitamente tutti questi pani hanno
all'interno una croce greca Questo è un
pane un po' particolare ha un quadrato
che indica la terra e l'intersezione tra
la Terra e il cielo
il ciclo della vita e il ciclo della
terra che si incontrano
ogni forma di pane è una forma di
comunicazione una preghiera fattissima
materiale
all'interno di una pagnotta di pane
spesso ci sono più informazioni più
culture che in tanti libri di storia il
pane viene utilizzato da sempre per
rendere grazie al cielo alla terra e
agli uomini che se ne possono citare
dietro ad ogni pagnotta ci sono tanti
mestieri Un po' come dietro ad uno di
noi e ci sono delle tradizioni
millenarie che sono importantissime che
ci tramandiamo di generazioni in
generazione Con gesti quasi inconsci
dell'uomo
il pane spesso non lo guardiamo forse a
volte andiamo troppo veloci e in un
mondo dominato dall'immediatezza Abbiamo
smesso di indagare sulle cose di
ricercare di attendere di conoscere
veramente il pane ci insegna e mi ha
insegnato tantissime cose innanzitutto a
saper gestire le imperfezioni lo
facciamo con le mani con una materia
modellabile mi ha insegnato i tempi e
che per raggiungere i risultati spesso
bisogna attendere grazie Al pane Ho
imparato che ogni cosa nella vita non si
fa in un attimo alcune volte ci possono
volere anche 23 anni per raggiungere un
solo risultato
ed è frutto ogni cosa nella nostra vita
è frutto di tanti passaggi che se solo
non ne fai bene uno tutto il resto va a
farsi benedire
Nietzsche diceva che è più facile
abbandonare una passione piuttosto che
controllarla e dedicarsi a una passione
richiede perseveranza perché le cose non
arrivano quasi mai subito io sono nipote
di un nonno appassionato che mi ha
insegnato con l'esempio che spesso i
lavori più umili sono quelli che se
fatti con passione ti possono rendere la
vita meravigliosa come Il Mugnaio il
panificatore e il contadino E penso che
come è stato fatto per me è la cosa più
bella sia trasferirla questa passione ai
nostri figli ai nostri nipoti alle
nostre famiglie e ai nostri amici Le
persone che stanno intorno a noi e come
lievito madre che trasmette ad un
impasto la vita e moltiplicandosi lo
trasforma in pane anche la passione può
essere contagiosa e può farci diventare
qualcosa di migliore
Ma le passioni A volte bisogna vederle
Non è sempre facile Io penso che la
passione sia un dono che ci viene dato e
viene dato a tutti La passione non
dobbiamo crearla dobbiamo semplicemente
trovarla come le cose semplici sono
quelle che spesso diamo per scontate Ma
che sono le più importanti magari
lavoriamo davanti ai nostri occhi sulla
tavola come il pane che spesso non viene
considerato per la sua importanza la
miglior lezione che possiamo dare Sulla
passione è quella che non deve essere
spiegata Ma che si lascia trapelare dal
nostro tono di voce e dalla luce che
brillano i nostri occhi quando facciamo
qualcosa che amiamo Mi commuovo un po'
mentre lo dico
[Musica]
Grazie
impariamo a riconoscere in quei momenti
e quel brivido che ci percorre lungo la
schiena quando facciamo qualcosa che
amiamo e che non ci fa sentire la fatica
come diceva Calvino dobbiamo imparare a
volare come delle farfalle leggeri
all'inseguimento perpetuo delle cose
proprio come chi ha passione e che non
si ferma mai
il pane in fondo siamo noi Noi siamo
tutti Pani di forme diverse ma con gli
stessi ingredienti di partenza ma ognuno
si è guidato al proprio istinto ma
soprattutto dalla propria passione può
dar vita ad un risultato unico e
dirripetibile grazie
[Applauso]